au fil des ans les petites et moyennes
laiteries avaient presque complètement
disparu au canada mais récemment
l'intérêt pour les aliments de proximité
à faire renaître le concept de micro
laiteries voici le portrait d'une
famille qui valorise le lait de son
troupeau à la ferme
il est 6 heures du matin en abitibi il
ne fait pas encore jours à saint félix
de dalquier
c'est bien silencieux dans les tables
c'est plutôt dans le bâtiment d'à côté
que la fermière s'activent
evelyne roncourt en bouteille le lait du
troupeau de manière artisanale pour le
vendre elmer
c'est le lait de nos vaches josé pendant
bouteille ce matin ce qui tout frais de
cette nuit où d'hier soir on le passe
temps est maintenant pour le met en
bouteille et on va l'envoyer bientôt
pour qui ce passe droit
la productrice de lait détient un permis
du sinn même s'il s'agit d'une micro les
tricks
grosso modo à chaque semaine on fait de
800 à 1200 l'hypnose c'est variable
l'été l'hiver la consommation diminue ça
me prend une heure et demie une heure
une heure et demie c'est fait
voici les bêtes dont le lait est
valorisée pour en faire un relais
fermiers
[Musique]
elles sont aux soins de benoît la
rochelle la transformation du lait et le
projet de sa femme evelyne mais c'est
lui qui mène le troupeau
de vaches en lactation
pour un troupeau total
la fâcheuse et donne moi de l'est que
les autres races laitières mais elle est
la championne du pourcentage de matières
grasses
comme convierait plus riches
la vache la plus populaire la noir et
blanc holstein donley à un taux de 4 %
de matière grasse le lait entier vendus
en épicerie et partiellement écrémé et
standardisés à 3,25 pour cent de
matières grasses
la petite jersey du troupeau de benoît
est largement en tête
l'ona prenante mais elle est autour de 5
le lait de la ferme est pasteurisé et
enrichi de vitamines d et vendu tel quel
plus crémeux non homogénéiser c'est ce
que les gens aiment dont le lait fermier
c'est sûr que cela que son frère le
[Rires]
lait fermier n'a pas l'aspect de celui
que les consommateurs connaissent depuis
l'avènement des grandes laiteries il y a
plus de 50 ans
pour plusieurs un lait entier qui n'est
pas homogénéiser représenter une mise en
marché aux et c'est du moins ce que
pense et le frère des villes visitées
welt en l'air je pense que je n'étais
pas seul mais moi j'avais aussi éditer
et pour mon genesee les gens sont pas
habitués la crème ramon
plus crémeux pensions pas totalement
vrai mais ceux-là mais finalement ça se
disent pris assez vite parce qu'on n'a
pas fourni les premiers mots font c'est
pas la demande en fait
les de proximité avec son aspect et goût
d'autrefois il connaît une récente
popularité au québec et ailleurs au pays
mais il existe un savoir faire
d'autant plus qu'elle a ajouté yu goût
du fromage cheddar à son offre en termes
d'horaires donc m a vida vert s'est
plaint même genre au pays en vertu
d'ententes les producteurs délèguent
leurs représentants la vente la fixation
des prix et la mise en marché du lait
chez les recours la rochelle la moitié
de la production est écoulée de cette
manière le reste est vendu litres par
lettre à des marchés de proximité
j'ai développé un
nouveau métier je ne connaissais pas ça
va de la transformation en fait parce
que j'étais pas fromage un match était
agronome gestion d'entreprise les
employés parce qu'au début on n'était
que trois métiers c'est le grossier tout
gérer le côte avec la fédération tout
gérer le côté que ma part que tu le côté
sanitaire pour cela mise en marché avec
le détail à la distribution
c'est passionnant en faire
aujourd'hui dimanche jour de marché
public à rouyn noranda il pleut mais les
habitués sont au rendez vous
il s'agit du premier d'un produit est
embouteillée en abitibi témiscamingue
ce qu'est pour plusieurs devient parfois
un tour de force s'est fait
naturellement pour evelyne rancourt et
l'a obtenu de l'espace tablette en
épicerie on est bien content and their
convoi de matagami qui est juste on a
redit si ma deux heures ce sont nos deux
hard si jusqu'au bout du témiscamingue
pour générer au dollar de revenu en
production agricole les besoins en
actifs sont énormes c'est différent en
transformation evelyne semble y trouver
son compte
voilà bharti sonara les équipements tout
ça mesalles aucune commune mesure avec
ce que ça nécessite en production et en
frais de rentrée d'argent mais ton pour
en dollars générés j'ai besoin de
beaucoup moins d'actifs en fait on s'en
rend compte mais capable de calculer
entre les deux la fromagerie avoir 3 et
puis ça peut être trop long qu'on a
dépensé chiffre d'affaires de la ferme
un succès certes mais pour la mère de
famille réalisée au prix de bien des
jeux forts le beaucoup de gens qui me
demandent comment qu'on fait ça mais on
a beaucoup d'ail qui désirent pas sont
élevés là dedans c'est comme ça qu'ils
sont élevés ils sont avec nous je pense
que c'est un modèle pour eux aussi texte
samedi en fait mais j'ai beaucoup d'ail
j'ai beaucoup d'amis
à commencer par la famille
[Musique]
louis la rochelle le frère de benoît
effectué l'administration de la ferme
les parents de benoît viennent tous les
jours amuser les enfants et voir aux
animaux cette ferme appartenait au grand
père de benoît le père de sa mère gisèle
c'est qu'à mon père à son décès quelques
mois 20 montréal et ici ici avait alors
il me dit la ferme on va la vendre et
puis l'eau benoît qui était à québec à
ce moment à l'eau au téléphone a pour
père puis à 10 bons progrès importants
je m'en viens
et benoît a rencontré vinh et ensemble
ils ont fait la paire
on développe pas en avant direct du lait
ils ont construit nouvelle étable et
acheter un robot de traite
[Musique]
des vaches acceptable pour mon ambition
après coup le couple le réalise il
n'avait pas mesurer l'immensité de la
tâche
au début début début car je me suis
lancé dans cette aventure là je me
souviens que la première semaine j'ai
appelé chine où la première semaine
piégeuse journée de la mention parce que
je me sens mais pleure je dois je
voudrais pas vous un peu de bon set up
bassin puis le les gens étaient
tellement rendez vous tout simplement
part il me demandait le arrête de
pleurer s'ils avaient pas personnes d'où
venait le type aurait pleuré mais ça va
tellement bien raide de pleurer et je me
suis bien raison
[Musique]
le lait embouteillée à la ferme ne
représente qu'un pour cent des 3
milliards de litres de lait produits
chaque année au québec ce sont des leds
d'exception il y en ad'autres l'étrier à
travers le québec puis je pense que
chaque laiterie comme la lande au son
goût unique en fait
pour le terroir de saint félix de
dalquier c'est le goût des fourrages et
de l'avoine de la ferme de nos régions
pour la production
la création d'une micro laiterie est un
immense projet scène de saint félix de
dalquier a nécessité l'entraidé la force
de toute une famille
les ranc ur la rochelle c'était l'amour
de la ferme qui a dominé dans tout ça
moi je viens les petites témiscamingue
je suis fier de venir ici
[Musique]